I go out with D.L Hughley like that's
one of my guys the nicest guy in the
world greatest guy and he always knows
great restaurants right so
he takes us to some crazy upscale [__]
and we ordered like a fish that was like
a [__] five six pound thing and it
and it's like beautifully and we cut it
all of us can eat it because it comes
out it's so big wow but the eyes and
everything yeah yeah so they bring about
boom he's smoking still he's like yeah
and then they cut it and it's almost
like a pan seared or like a fried thing
but when you cut it and the meat is just
soft and moist but but the outside is
kind of like a nice crisp but what what
if you saw that fish what would you do I
would eat ice first ice first you're
gonna get the eyes
Asians eat the eye first okay fish
cheeks fish eyes fish tails
especially if it's deep fried taller so
the head of the fish is my favorite
thing to boil it is so flavorful the
cheek is so meaty and probably the
softest part of the fit
and so but the eyes when you fry it
right is just a chip it's so crunchy
delicious yeah yeah I look like yeah
mouth Warners
I I do agree that I love this is I'm
getting I'm getting my Filipino on right
here I think that like the tail you
write like there's a crispiness to it
it's like and it's somehow the seasoning
is in that yeah like you know I know
what you mean but I never ate the eyes
okay so when you fry a whole fish try
eating the eye first because it's very
it's almost like it's the saltiest part
it seems like yeah it concentrates the
salt to help you see the future that's
what our parents would say that's what
they would say I would say if you bite
into it the juices squirting your mouth
let's get it together
you know what no you might want to clear
this up just you know this is a show
ER
okay well you guys were talking about
the eyes in my mind I was like do fish
have dick and then when it came out I go
I think I've eaten the dip but it came
out wrong right right I'm glad you did
that make sure this face in itself
I think some fish they just released the
sperm into in the water right but like
like forget like fish too fishes I shoot
fish
can we get back on topic okay let's go
back on top I want to know about the
mermaid basically yeah yeah so basically
like you forget that like a tiger shark
is a fish okay a whale shark is a fan
and they have dicks I know they have
very different anatomies than something
like a Parrotfish say for instance not
only parrot fish can turn from female to
male depending on what the community
trans
yeah do they drink Bud Light
now
they love Bud Light
what is wrong with that I don't know at
my point so there's trans fish yeah like
for instance like some sharks there are
some new every day like you think like
fish just lay eggs but some sharks they
do live births they're there's like such
a range in their Anatomy so it's hard to
so you're basically some fish like
little sardines and stuff they don't
they don't have dicks no sardines
wouldn't have dicks yeah yeah they would
just probably release their uh they just
go and then it just gets in the water
and then it grabs the eggs or something
but I think see but I've seen it before
for whatever yeah yeah why do you know
that I don't know it's just a random
thing I've seen and then the other thing
that I've seen is like sea horses have
little penises oh I love sea horses
because I saw I saw it on like I saw it
I saw it on like a little bit I have a
very good dreams
I dream in seahorses no but I saw like
they it was like he has a little thing
it's like I was like oh [__] oh [__]
like it isn't something like you know
like the human penis like blood flow
causes it to engorgeous you can actually
remove a whale bone because my marine
biology Professor would use it as like
the thing to start a punch in this party
it was that hard it was a bone so y'all
stir just do it well dick oh my God look
at that thing dude
whoa
dude and he's also black so he's all
black yeah yes
he see you see at the bottom of that
dick is black
do what the [__]
look at that thing oh dude that's
amazing wow man I didn't know I was
gonna learn so much
I had no idea what I was walking into
that's [__] amazing though that Wales
have you guys heard this recently
knowledge like she just sees the best so
quiet and she's got she's killing the
game right now the animal stuff oh my
God go ahead so lately there there have
been these pack of killer whales that
are sinking boats off the coast yeah I
don't know why they're doing it though
but we do know why so it turns out one
of I think her I forget what her name
was Gladys there was an uh an orca named
Gladys named Gladys
who named it does she go I'm Gladys she
might have been Tagged so oh some some
white person called her Gladys her name
could have been Laquisha though yeah yes
yes yes it could have been anything but
it was glad because it's an auntie well
that's a very nice
so she recently got injured by either
one of the propellers of the book but
she sustained an injury from
um a vessel and so what they're
theorizing now is that she's taught
other killer whales in her pack to
basically retaliate on her behalf and so
they've been going after boats and
sinking them whoa so they're like
Italian I mean they have like there's
emotions you know they have really big
brains possibly like more communicating
yeah they communicate seamlessly
it's kind of scary right like Mafia
style so they was like what happened let
me tell you what happened yeah so Gladys
was chilling and [__] right I didn't
know okay so Gladys was swimming around
and [__] whatever and she was having a
good time her and her cousins and
whatever
what happened was they was having a good
[__] day yeah you know they was
feeding they were having a good time in
this you know big ass vessel came in hit
her boom boom blew her [__] shoulder
out [__] and she was hurting
yeah and the pack was like yo what the
[__] happened to Gladys yeah the Gladys
was like the [__] they hit me
with that goddamn bro and they didn't
even say sorry whoa what because Gladys
is the chick right everyone that come
through here we shutting it down whoa so
that's what went down because I've seen
three different things on the internet
ironically you said that where they're
coming out the water hit me bro because
they could come from the bottom right
they're coming out they're breaching
boom whoa and ain't nothing we could do
nothing it ain't no it ain't a damn
thing a human can do if the killer whale
comes out the water and just the slides
to slam his body on your thing you
better get in the water yeah but my
point though is is that you could you
could do this just not go there isn't
the ocean big it's a very very can't
they go that's where Gladys family is
but that's like imagine if they travel
though that's the thing they don't just
stay in their name oh I didn't know that
I didn't know that see you know so they
go from you know I mean um watts to Long
Beach
this is in Spain right but then there's
like orcas in Seattle and like the
Pacific Northwest ocean is more than we
can understand bro these things move
with temperature these things move to
get to feed for a certain time then go
back over here and they go yo they're
interesting
I'm with you I'm starting to get all
deep yeah but but but they're just an
interesting um they have their own
ecosystem like they really really are
well managed beings they really are the
way they hunt is so organized yeah it's
like a trip right if you get into it I
don't know why I'm in I'm going I'm kind
of geeky bro was that old English man
that does Attenborough and burrow yeah
you should do them from now on oh what
was that yo Davido Animal Kingdom he's
the voiceover oh my God you should be
the guy you think I should do it you'll
be the [__] best dude I learned more
you might be yeah because I'm gonna make
it more interesting yeah yeah